do I think that human beings will ever
come into contact with aliens in our
lifetime I don't know do you think now
the aliens are starting to realize also
that Vegas is the place to be I think I
think they're all moving to Vegas
because it's real cheap I feel like when
they landed in California they got
jacked by like a meth head yep the
catalytic converter
[Music]
how many of you guys saw the recent
story in Las Vegas about the Alien
aliens yeah
I put the link in the group chat you son
of a [__] that means you guys didn't
even click it oh I liked it I liked it I
didn't like I didn't see it I'm sorry so
um let's go over some of the things that
happened there so basically uh just to
give you the juice yeah I
basically something fell from the sky
some glowing objects yeah and then
everything a lot of people saw it it got
caught on police body cam yeah and then
after it landed a family dialed 9-1-1 to
report seeing aliens in their backyard
like 10 foot 10 foot people or something
let's let's gauge your believability at
this point yeah how how high do you
believe this I'm like a eight okay an
eight out of 100.
everyone said you know this day and age
everyone pulls out the phone immediately
and Records why didn't you and they're
like when I looked at them and they
looked back they I got Frozen that's
what he said okay so here's we'll go bit
by bit here's the footage of the object
falling from the body cam just so you
can see it sick that's the police body
cam but there's another footage now too
whoa yeah it's a it's like a meteor did
you see that in Summerlin dude no you
didn't see it huh no nobody clicked my
God dang leak I put the put in a group
chat I guess
I looked at it I just didn't I just
didn't the moral of this video is we
have to pay attention to the group chat
more
so so here's the 9-1-1 call that the
family uh dialed in
so you can hear what they say it's
pretty creepy
in my backyard
I swear to God this is not a joke this
is actually weird so there's two people
or two subjects that are in your
backyard
correct and they're very large
they're like so he could call but how
come his friend can't record
their tiny eyes and
they're not human they're 100 they're
not human he's all right man all right I
don't know dude do you think he's high I
think he's high he sounds a little I
remember being a young man and you know
what I would have done if I saw the
alien ship like that I'll be like oh
[__] you'll be so funny if we caught
9-1-1 right now and say like we saw
aliens
called oh [__]
oh [__] I think that's exactly what
happened you saw that [__] he goes oh oh
call call and save you saw alien yeah
that's [__] hilarious that's probably
they got the whole family in on it dude
the whole family are just like
everyone's like yeah we saw it they are
receiving a lot of uh backlash kind of
for like people from people that believe
they're faking the whole thing yeah the
whole time I guess like what what
experts said is that because of the
amount of time that you could see it it
kind of falls under the meteorite
category oh because it's it's like three
to five seconds because the true um the
ones that they've seen the one that
looks like a Tic Tac it's like crazy
fast right
and it changes Direction yeah it's a
weird way like it doesn't go like
like that it doesn't have like a flight
pattern yeah a normal one right here's a
another video of them uh when it when
they first discovered this is the guy
this is the one of the Suns yeah yeah
what happened that's when they're
looking at the aliens well how come
she's not recording the alien the lady
she's a little jumpy she's a little
scared she's recording her family's
freaking jeans great jeans you gotta get
the ring so
um they're saying that he was saying too
that when they went out there to look at
the um to see the aliens that there was
like a blurriness in the area
it wasn't in his eyes he said that the
area was from the carnazada yeah the
smoke dude
we found out that's the carne asada they
were having a cookout they were having a
cookout hey we're having a carne asada
from the barbecue because they cook it
real hot
real hot Grill yeah the grill has those
heat waves you know right and then the
charcoal dude another fun thing is that
they um and it is very fun to read these
details because they're all like out of
different movies we've seen they said
there was like an SUV with government
plates that were circling the area men
in suits and this black guy came in
punched the alien right in the face they
said welcome to Earth
yeah it all happened I swear to God I
thought
right it's kind of like um it's it's a
little like like you're pointing out
it's very perfect in the sense that
there's not enough to really have
irrefutable evidence but there's enough
to like make it a fun story to like this
is what we love yeah we love it yeah
there was a um podcast I just watched of
uh he's like a military guy
that was talking about the U.S does have
like flying objects
and I was like oh [__] this is cool I
gotta save it to watch later and then
because I didn't finish it and I went
and it's gone yeah that he's like an
ex-agent that uh he's basically doing a
tell-all where he's talking about how uh
like the US has a disinformation
campaign to dissuade people from
believing in UFOs and that they have
retrieved crashed UFOs in the past yeah
so he but then the thing is though how
dare you watch another podcast by the
way yeah what the [__] I don't know they
they they took it out so like I couldn't
find the video anymore should I put in
the group chat
yeah
but the thing is it's always these like
he didn't see himself but he has access
to top officials that all confided into
him he put a petition to disclose but I
mean come on man how many people are
gonna actually you think that see if he
tells the CIA dear CIA I think I
urgently urge you to disclose here yeah
right he sends the official letter like
please disclose the American people have
the right to know stop keeping secrets
you [__] sincerely with love you know
like if he sends that official letter
they're gonna be like [__] why should I
tell you trash yeah yeah this this story
definitely does have a lot of really fun
details if you guys look it up every
little thing on there it's just fun to
read but there's nothing that will make
you go that's for sure an alien sadly I
was hoping it would yeah when I first
saw the the title I thought they caught
the 10-foot people on the body cam I'm
like oh [__] that's crazy I'm curious
where it landed so they got this yard
that's like they got this huge property
that's all it's like red style so they
got like an excavator they got all this
equipment back there yeah great thanks
Vegas sounds real awesome
but did it actually land in their
backyard so they're claiming that yeah
it did land and then there's a the funny
thing is they claim that it left this
perfect circle in the middle which there
is a circle there but there's also a lot
of other nice curves that's their
[__] chicken fighting ring things
yeah yeah yeah see so when I was trying
to cover that up Yeah Yeah by saying
there's aliens it landed in your
backyard and you're like oh
there's a stereotypical reason I know
you're supposed to dead chickens
everywhere culture does dude
Colleen what do you think aliens or not
no you don't think so you're not a
Believer I feel like you're a skeptic
bro do you think aliens do exist though
um I I think that the universe is so
vast that there's got to be some sort of
possibility that something else exists
um especially since there's so many
different species on just this one
planet so I think so
um do I think that human beings will
ever come into contact with aliens in
our lifetime I don't know
do you think now the aliens are starting
to realize also that Vegas is the place
to be I think I think they're all moving
to Vegas because it's real cheap I feel
like when they landed in California they
got jacked by like a meth head yep the
catalytic converter
landed they got out and they're like
earthlings and then some junkie came and
started like taking off their converter
yeah
like oh no and
oh it's Vegas and like oh it is much
better I really thought if an alien was
gonna visit Las Vegas he would have
landed on Luxor or something like
something yeah it's gonna they put all
that money into having a beacon he lands
its Mexican guys backyard
the aliens are not that smart aim for
that they won't be low-key dude it is
pretty interesting I think they smelled
the carne asada yeah they were
probably chickens all stacked up that
was the big eyes you know what's funny
if so lots of people there's the only
thing in here that's really proven is
there was uh something that flew down
they don't know if it landed in their
yard but everybody saw it like the cops
saw it different people have it on their
ring cams it is like a thing that
existed if it's true that they really
did see that and they go hey let's all
act like it landed that's pretty funny
yeah that's actually pretty smart that's
smart but there's a community of it
right for nest cameras yeah yeah yeah
there's footage of it in their backyard
it it just goes like like that like a
shooting star yeah but they did not have
surveillance camera at the spot where
the aliens were uh they said that I mean
I guess they did but they said that the
video went out right when it happened
because ring camera doesn't capture the
first five seconds of anything that
walks by it really that's probably
[__] one of them really cameras are
[__] a joke that's why they gotta get
a Google name their details are pretty
wild though they said that like at one
point one of the creatures tried to get
in one of the like the backhoes or the
excavators and try to use it or
something yeah they said that he got it
and he was just trying to like which is
[__] which is hilarious that an
alien that can operate this highly
Advanced right like what's this
gets into a freaking cat and goes huh
yeah where he gets into one of the
lowriders
I don't know how to use this stuff I
don't know how to use that I mean
Interstellar travel yes but uh up and
down left to right John dears no thanks
but how do we know what they look like
it's movies of yeah
big eyes tall yeah that's another thing
that's interesting is whenever people
say they see aliens they describe an
alien from a movie that we've all seen
yeah right I'm almost expected he's like
come on something completely different
yeah or Indescribable do you think if
there are actual aliens that touched on
Earth and they actually looked like like
the hacky alien thing do you think
everyone's gonna be bummed out oh man
they look like these [__] things like
the Alien Beef Jerky guy that's what
looks so yeah just like the big ass like
dome right I don't believe it I probably
won't believe what do you hope aliens
really look like
Independence Day dude yeah I hope they
look like that let me tell you with all
the tentacles and the and they open up
and there's a smaller guy you like that
do you like that
best case scenario what if aliens just
look like us but I think they look like
blonde Scandinavians yo but with
cauliflower here would you be happy
I think they're just humans you think so
I think they're coming as humans check
it out
no
display saying it you don't think they'd
be impressed by Earth no hell no yeah
the way it's going right now like real
Thor the way it's going right now hell
no
you're probably chilling at Skid Row
right now they probably yeah like men in
black dude yeah they're probably like
that
so nobody here believes this family no
no but I believe that alien's already
here oh yeah yep there you go you when
do you think they got here
they've been here oh
2020. I think they are the mechanics of
Earth to keep it going
so they're like trying to fix things
behind the scenes oh that's kind of a
tight Theory like the Dalai Lama intern
[__] up yeah this year like [__] [__]
buy this present bam
[Music]